في طهران التقى الامين العام لمجلس الامن
الروسي نيكولايبات روشيف بالرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي ونظيره الايراني علي شمخاني
اللقاء تطرق لبحث الوضع في اوكرانيا
والترتيبات لمواجهات التدخل الغربي في
شؤونهم الداخليه
روسيه السلطات الايرانيه
وروسيا على الرغم من الاتهامات لطهران
بدعم موسكو وعسكري
اطلاق النار والسلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا
على اساس الحجاره
تقارير الاستخباراتيه غربيه تقول ان طهران
اضحى تلعب دورا هاما في الحرب الاوكرانيا
عبر دعم الجيش الروسي بانظمه العسكريه
الولايات المتحده واوكرانيه تهاماتها
بتزويد روسيا بطائره من طراز شهيد 136
استعملت الاستهداف للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه
في اوكرانيا
قبل ان تعود للاعتراف بانها سلمت شحنه
صغيره من الطائره المسجله لروسيا قائله
انها اشترتها منها قبل اندلاع الحرب ونفتت
بالمقابل لتسليم
واقتصاديا وسياسيين
مع الولايات المتحده